hey guys crs ago aged beer has released
an official promo entitled long walk the
features Jon Snow Cersei Lannister the
nearest Targaryen and the blue-eyed
white Walker who should be the night
King since this user contains only the
Queen's and the king this problem is
very more interesting than an teaser
that has been released since in this
video HBO provided the first official
look at characters which accompanied
with all those magnificent Reynolds
makes this promo perfect it starts with
dreaming characters walking through the
halls of their seeds Jon Snow walking to
the host of interval with an outside
that extremely reminds me on Ned Stark
the nearest Targaryen welcome to the
halls of Dragonstone in an outfit that
matches the colors of her house and
Cersei Lannister walk into the holes of
the red keep in the outfit similar to
her season 6 finale outfit after an asst
title says itself long walk through the
halls all three characters are entering
their trim rooms whereupon they continue
walking toward their drones sources well
the official confirmed new look of the
Great Hall aka the throne room about
which I'm going to talk about a bit more
in a few moments after the long walk the
nearest sits on the brain enthroned that
we are going to see a dragon stone
Cersei sits on the Iron Throne and Jon
Snow sits on the same place the last
time so on as they've set on their
trends camera zooms in on their face ver
Pandey shada rides along with candles
being extinguished next scene is
definitely my favorite efficacy by
Cersei Lannister breath winter has come
far south all the way to the King's
Landing but for all of it it's are
following my work here this is not
surprising as a few months ago I brought
you fuelly photos in which we could see
jeremy preswick with directing season 7
premiere and finale shooting a few
scenes in da burning a beautiful city
that will continue portraying parts of
King's Landing however after shooting a
few scenes for season 7 premiere Viet
Lena Headey nomina Cersei and with
Nikolaj coster-waldau known as Jamie
Jeremy continue filming scenes without
any actor on the shooting set on snow
machine which generates fake snow had
been seen beside a fact that doe burning
has always been portraying parts of
King's Landing em aside Lannister flags
that have been seen hanging on the wall
search his breath official confirmed
that winter will come all the way to the
Kings Lane
upon Circe's breath which is a clear
sign of aventure being present through
the most of the Seven Kingdoms at some
point of the seventh season video ends
with an eye of the white Walker who in
my opinion should be the night King as
this video contains only a Queen's and
the King as you can see in the upcoming
season they will have modified throne
room and one totally new town which is
not surprising at all since several
photos so both of those rooms were
shared on social medias by a visitor to
the in Dorset Titanic studios in delphos
a few months ago I brought you live
photos of the modified from room at red
keep in which I said that exact
modification is replacement of seven
point in star adorning the window above
the Iron Throne which is going to be
replaced by a line but with this
official video not only that they
confirm this but also revealed that the
line will join the side windows which
looks pretty amazing let's also say one
or two sentences about the tollon you
thrown a dragon stone which has also
been leaked a few months ago but it's
now officially confirmed long story
short the nurse will end in Dragonstone
on the east coast of Westeros which is
the ancestral seat of House Targaryen
and will sit on the new drone just as
the Queen deserves and as always let me
know your opinion about all of this in
the comment section down below hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see in the next
piece
[Music]